[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 le journal
voici le sommaire le premier tour de la
primaire de la gauche c'est ce dimanche
des élus socialistes des yvelines joue
le tout pour le tout pour leur poulain
c'était le cas hier de la sénatrice
catherine tasca arrêté à la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines pour une
ultime distribution de tracts pour
manuel valls la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines a
inauguré lundi 16 janvier à versailles
son point d'accueil nouvelle génération
des nouveaux services mis à disposition
pour faciliter les démarches du public
et puis un peu de sport on parlera de
muay-thaï la boxe talent thaïlandaise
était à l'honneur ce week end dans les
yvelines
un grand gala était organisé nous étions
sur place
on débute ce journal avec de la
politique dimanche se déroulera le
premier tour de la primaire de la gauche
dans le département les élus socialistes
jettent leurs dernières forces dans la
bataille comme la sénatrice catherine
tasca qui était hier à la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines pour une ultime
distribution de tracts en faveur de
manuel passe la campagne a beau être
difficile pour lui catherine tasca on
est convaincu manuel valls est à même de
l'emporter la sénatrice socialiste des
yvelines on a fait son favori pour le
scrutin de cette primaire loin devant
benoît hamon pourtant élu du département
des yvelines
c'est un camarade nous respectons ses
choix qui ne sont pas les nôtres qui ne
sont pas les nôtres dont on dira pour
parler je dirais sans sans agressivité
qui lie à une bonne part d'utopie et un
comportement qui a été le sien et
d'autres à l'égard de notre parti qui ne
nous paraît pas fidèle à l'histoire de
ce parti
l'ancien ministre de françois mitterrand
soutien de manuel valls elle estime
qu'il est aujourd'hui le seul à avoir la
stature d'un chef d'état dans le
deuxième débat il est le seul à avoir
prononcé le mot de culture et vous
comprenez que pour moi ça compte mais
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui parle de
l'europe de façon à la fois très très
réaliste mais également active avec
cette distribution de tracts les
militants entendent et clarifier les
propositions de leurs candidats un
candidat qui suscite l'intérêt du public
selon lui les gens effectivement demande
à connaître un peu plus aussi du
programme demande à connaître un peu
plus des axes qui vont être donnés
durant la campagne pour la presse et je
pense que là du coup le retour et poésie
parce que les gens cherchent à connaître
reste que l'épisode de la gifle reçue
par l'ancien premier ministre mardi soir
pourrait laisser des traces manuel valls
et est annoncé en tête dans les sondages
à l'issue du premier tour mais battu au
second
que ce soit par arnaud montebourg benoît
hamon justement lundi dernier la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie a inaugurés
à versailles son nouveau point d'accueil
des nouveaux outils et des services qui
sont mis à disposition du public pour
améliorer leur démarche
ouvert depuis fin décembre le but de cet
accueil nouvelle génération et 2
s'amplifier les démarches du public et
d'améliorer leur accueil
si on accompagne pas les outils ne
seront pas utilisées donc en fait c'est
le pari qu'on a fait c'est de mettre les
outils à disposition et de former nos
techniciens d'accueil aux techniques
d'accompagnement et d'ailleurs ça marche
puisque en 2014 nous avions un petit peu
moins de 40 % des assurés yvelinois qui
avaient un compte emilie est aujourd'hui
fin 2016 on est à plus de 66 % des
assurés qui ont un compte ameli et
depuis qu'on a mis en place le nouvel
accueil mais qu'on accompagne nos
assurés sur les outils on voit bien
qu'il ya une montée en charge très forte
du compte ameli il ya l'accompagnement
qui permet de fluidifier le passage du
public
mais il est aussi de nombreuses bornes
mises à disposition avec de nombreux
services
ces bornes nous permettent de gagner du
temps en mettant à jour les cartes
vitale en imprimant les attestations de
droit en commandant des cartes
européennes en consultant les relevés de
remboursement et en imprimant des
attestations de paiement d'indemnités
journalières
elles sont disponibles pour tous nos
clients et tout au long de la journée
tous ces outils permettent aux agents de
la cpam de se concentrer sur les
rendez-vous avec le public
le délai d'attenté est aujourd'hui de 48
heures
et depuis le mois de novembre lémanique
want un nouvel espace citoyen ce site
permet de réaliser diverses démarches
administratives comme s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales ou encore trouver des
offres d'emploi écoutez bertrand ou lyon
le maire de la commune pouvoir trouver
tous les services facilement pouvoir
aussi interagir avec la commune avec les
services municipaux et les élus
donc c'est par exemple signalé des
problèmes c'est suggérer des idées s'est
félicité aussi quand on voit des choses
qui se passent bien et est cet outil là
on en voit une information
au service qui les gèrent qui répondent
le plus vite possible qui donne une
réponse et qui essaye d'apporter
toujours une solution
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du projet
demos une quinzaine de jeunes trappistes
ont reçu des instruments de musique
un dispositif coordonné par la
philharmonie de paris qui vise à
démocratiser la pratique musicale en
orchestre et le week-end dernier ils
étaient aussi à plaisir nous étions sur
place
violon alto ou contrebasse des
instruments que ses enfants tiennent
pour la première fois entre leurs mains
grâce au projet demos menée par la
philharmonie de paris
ces quinze jeunes plaisir oies ont reçu
leurs propres instruments
si le vivre tu peux les transporter chez
moi et est si basse qu'il est il peut et
est-ce que je laime de vidéos killers
sont il faut et imite ne dise j'ai déjà
appris à faire un petit peu les
instruments et des villes a appris à
chanter et à danser au fur à mesure on
apprend les notes on apprend à jouer
d'instruments et puis et puis à
rejoindre les autres les autres groupes
c'est à dire les flûtistes les
clarinettistes durant trois ans chaque
enfant suivra quatre heures de cours par
semaine avec sa famille d'instruments
initié en 2010 demos veut démocratiser
la musique classique auprès des
populations ne disposant pas d'un accès
facile à cette pratique
c'est quelque chose qui est fort et qui
va non seulement je dirais leur
permettre de rencontrer la musique mais
aussi de faire changer leur comportement
de les accompagner dans une forme de
rigueur de joie d'optimisme et aussi de
fédération puisque ce groupe de 15 à
plaisir rencontre les autres groupes de
15 de toutes les villes et donc
régulièrement ils vont se sentir en
appartenance avec d'autres enfants c'est
important
en france une centaine de communes est
concerné par ce dispositif plus de 3000
enfants pourront découvrir
l'appartenance à un orchestre les jeunes
de plaisir participeront au grand
concert organisé
les autres groupes à la fin de l'année
et on reste à plaisir avec les voeux de
la mère joséphine coleman ce berger
mercredi dernier au gymnase nicole a
summer lors de la cérémonie elle est
notamment revenu sur la réhabilitation
du château de plaisir dans les prochains
mois
on a un très grand projet est un prêt un
projet d'un centre culturel à
l'intérieur y'a pas uniquement du
château mais aussi des communs du
château qui doit complètement renouvelée
cet endroit pour pouvoir déplacer la
bibliothèque et surtout avoir un centre
numérique puisque aujourd'hui que ce
soit les livres que ce soit la musique
le théâtre c'est avec le numéro au
projet de réhabilitation de l'ensemble
du château et des communs un projet de
fans mandature très ambitieux un mot de
ce sport à présent le muay-thaï appelé
également boxe thaïlandaise étaient à
l'honneur le week end dernier dans les
yvelines
un grand gala était programmée à
conflans sainte honorine
une soirée qui a attiré des têtes
d'affiché nous étions sur place
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
sur des images divines première un
parfum de thaïlande a flotté sur
conflans sainte honorine ce samedi 14
janvier à gala de muay thaï tô organisé
pour la cinquième fois la capitale de la
batellerie
pour ce rendez vous plus de 1000
personnes ont fait le déplacement pour
voir ce sport de combat qui mêle les
techniques ou de pieds poings je loue
coude et les projections le public est
réceptif toujours à conflans c'est la
cinquième édition
et puis le tout le monde est là
pour des présents c'est un pas pour que
je travaille depuis quelques temps
maintenant et donc j'ai pris soin de
préparer ces combats minutieusement donc
là ce soit y aura du spectacle pour la
première fois un combat féminin pour la
ceinture wmc était programmée dans
l'enceinte entre la française myriam
jedidi la baisse walesa de wail
tricolore en bresse cire noire
l'emportent dans cet affrontement
je suis évidemment super contente
content de ma prestation est contente
d'avoir fait aux pisseurs plaisir au
public par dont apparemment ça leur a
plu le feu qui m'encourage arrivait
justement à monter le rythme chez les
hommes en full contact michel lopes da
veiga originaire de sartrouville cinq
fois champion de france champion
d'europe et champion du monde en titre
s'est imposé contre williams il le met
d'issy les moulineaux
c'est quand quelqu'un raf a passé un
adversaire très coriace madrid à
retordre et ça je le savais depuis le
début et non franchement c'est content
moi mais voilà enfin lorsque je
travaille beaucoup de choses à
l'entraînement
les bénéfices de cette soirée
permettront d'acheter du matériel pour
développer le muay thaï dans les
quartiers le montant exact n'a pas
encore été communiquée ils prennent de
sacrés coups on va à présent par les dix
porte le sport électronique sur consoles
en france des milliers de joueurs
participent à des tournois et récolte
des sommes considérables dans les
yvelines
un nom circule avec insistance celui de
qui viennent faut chaud à 14 ans il est
déjà considéré comme le lionel messi de
ce sport qu'il y ait une faucheuse 14
ans n'est pas un adolescent comme les
autres ce collégien le troisième est
actuellement considéré comme le futur
prodige dhuys portes en france du sport
via les jeux vidéo sa spécialité le
football jeune marque des buts avec sa
touche carré déplace ses joueurs avec
son joli stick depuis ses 6 ans quand
j'étais petit mon père un petit peu au
jeu vidéo avant j'étais tellement fort
que je perdais souvent et après je me
sens en train de s'entraîner s'entraîner
jouant un peu en ligne tht et du court
elle envie de jouer
vidéo change de foot m apparaît comme ça
après avoir emporté des centaines de
matchs en ligne killian alias kills ou
s'est fait un nom plutôt un pseudo dans
le milieu en 2015 il a intégré la neo x
porte ce 95 une équipe d'une quinzaine
d'adeptes composés sont les spécialistes
des meilleurs joueurs du monde sur les
jeux de football fifa et pes c'est mieux
pour beaucoup de choses pour est basse
et l'esprit d'équipé
il ya les tournois qui se font aussi en
équipe il ya toujours du président où
n'importe qui peut te dépanner pour
quelque chose s'est amené en tournoi on
part en plus à plusieurs c'est toujours
mieux partir tout seul à cinq heures de
route
une alchimie qui fonctionne qui viennent
a remporté des dizaines de tournois dont
celui de la paris games week
des performances qui lui ont permis
d'empocher près de 1500 euros cette
année
mais pour continuer à progresser le
sportif virtuel s'entraînent une heure
tous les jours une passion encouragé par
sa mère sous certaines conditions
je pousse à continuer mais comme tous
les parents à condition que kiel que
qu'ils soient sérieux au niveau de ces
notes et de ses études un entraînement
nécessaires pour accomplir son plus
grand rêve devenir le meilleur gens du
monde du x porte dans les prochaines
années
c'est la fin de ce cette ut le journal
merci de nous avoir suivis et surtout
bonne soirée
[Musique]